hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that's always in the
holiday spirit all the year around why
well not just because of this I also
enjoy wearing sweatpants gloves and a
Wool Cap I get cold easily it's a low
iron count but even all my peppermint
mocha mightiness can't compete with the
residents of The Ultimate Christmas
Village Whoville yeah them who's love
some festive wreaths mistletoe and
combat consumerism but out past the edge
of town there's one fella who's not so
high on the season of giving even though
he is green it's the
yeah the Grinch prefers to be all by his
Lonesome stewing about the goings-on in
the world with only the company of his
dog Max to pass the time and now that I
describe his lifestyle actually doesn't
sound like a bad way to live all right
don't worry I'll leave this place he's a
mean one although he's actually been in
numerous iterations over the years
kicking off with Dr Seuss's How the
Grinch Stole Christmas picture book
which dropped in 1957 decades before
we'd use the term drop for cool new
stuff arriving then Seuss an animation
genius Chuck Jones teamed up to make the
cartoon classic in 1966 which featured
our anti-hero voiced by Frankenstein
Legend Boris Karloff tomorrow is
Christmas is practically here while that
vintage 26 minute romp never goes out of
style or leaves our Airways for too long
a new Grinch emerged in the year 2000
thanks to a crap ton of makeup Jim
Carrey became the first live-action
Greenie and Ron Howard's feature link
How the Grinch Stole Christmas but we
weren't done yet 2018 brought us back to
the the world of Animation but we
remained in movie theaters for the
Grinch starring the voice of Benedict
Cumberbatch in yet another Smash Hit
iteration I'll be in your ear the whole
time if you haven't guessed by now
Today's show is going to be a gargantuan
green Gaggle going after Grinchy gold
who will emerge as the best holiday
hater of them all here's how we'll
determine a winner round one box office
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score round three iconic moments round
four such a clatter and then we'll do a
Wild Card round just in case we need
another stage to prove who is the Grinch
goat I'm your host Mark Ellison like
many of you the holiday season never
really gets going until you get a few
classic Grinch viewings under your belt
as I came of age in the 1990s I was
delighted to see one of my comedic Idols
Jim Carrey announced as the live-action
meanie and then a few years ago even
grizzled oldmark found his heart growing
three exercises by the Benedict
Cumberbatch iteration I love some
grinchiness I think we can all identify
with that character more than we'd like
to admit and at the very least man is
his Croatia will stayed on the side of
Mount Crumpet looked like a nice Airbnb
away from the hustle and bustle of
Whoville sorry honey give my best to the
kids I want to watch football on the
weekends and the Grinch has the NFL
package
buckle up you marry who's it's time to
poke the bear with a 39 and a half foot
pole Let's Get It On round one box
office
and right off the bat Dr Seuss Paris are
gonna be upset you see usually the box
office round is a pretty fair fight here
on versus our expert researcher Mark
Hoffmeyer who literally turns into a
grinch if he doesn't get to re-watch
Deep Blue Sea once a week he adjusts the
movie going monies for inflation so it's
a Level Playing Field but today we have
two movies and one cartoon that isn't
even 30 minutes so how is this fair to
the Elder Statesman aha ratings back in
the old days you had three channels if
the rabbit eared gods were feeling
generous that day but unfortunately
there's little data on how many folks
actually saw that initial viewing in
December of 1966 I blame it on Bob Dylan
going electric at the Newport Folk
Festival
oh that's a good one but we do know this
at some point in time three major
networks have run it during the holiday
season CBS initially aired it then ABC
picked it up in the mid-2000s and in
2015 NBC won the job plus it's been a
holiday constant on TNT TBS Cartoon
Network and the WB people love it to
this day and they warmed to it quick
amid a flurry of 1960s era Christmas
specials featuring folks like Charlie
Brown Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer and
Frosty the Snowman critic Rick Dubrow
said How the Grinch Stole Christmas is
quote probably as good as most of the
other holiday cartoons thanks for not
sugarcoating it rick that's High Praise
indeed but alas this round will likely
be won by a more modern take on the
classic crusty character
[Music]
cheer up dude it's Christmas two
thousands How the Grinch Stole Christmas
was a highly anticipated theatrical
release and why not it starred Jim Kerry
who's meteor-like rise to Comedy super
stardom in 1994 was still soaring across
the night sky more recently he had done
hits like Liar Liar but also expanded
his Horizons to dramedies like The
Truman Show and The biopic man on the
moon where he became Andy Kaufman yes
became is an accurate description the
Ron Howard directed film hit the
multiplex on November 17 2000 and was a
worldwide smash grossing and adjusted
for inflation 442 million dollars in the
United States alone and it was a good
thing it performed so well the movie's
budget inflated to 120 million dollars a
hundred million of which had to go to
makeup and costuming right the set
design is nuts in that movie too okay so
we got a beloved animation OG and now a
live-action companion what more could be
under the tree doesn't this seem like a
bit much a newer version that is feature
length like the 2000 iteration but is
animated like the original this one
simply called The Grinch which was a
better title for the abbreviated Emoji
loving generation than age
tgsc would have been it also raked in
enough cash to stuff presents under
every Christmas tree in Whoville 272
million dollars domestic to be exact and
while I can't imagine the budget of this
most recent version approaches that of
the 2000 take I'm going to bet both
updated films cost way more than the
1966 classic which was three hundred
thousand dollars and that was
extravagant in the 60s that equals
around 2 million dollars in today money
that's almost five times how much any
one episode of The Flintstones cost
having a dab of due time in this round
will be Jim Carrey's Christmas thieving
Grinch the live-action one takes round
one and goes up one to nothing to
nothing
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score and now with cyber relief for all
you kids over the age of however old you
were if you were born in 2000 you young
pups were you thinking about beer now
like by themselves not by me in a
7-Eleven parking lot
catch today uh my back hurts but it's
good news for fans of the OG Christmas
Tale because now we're in a whole new
round with new Fantastic measuring
sticks like how did the critics and
verified audience members feel about the
three Grinchy offerings after seeing
them if that Rick do brown note from the
60s is any indication the first How the
Grinch Stole Christmas has a puncher's
chance in this round okay let me update
that thought from puncher's chance to
Muhammad Ali I am the greatest territory
the 1966 holiday special is back with a
vengeance and floats like a butterfly
all the way to a perfect 100 on the
Tomato Meter wow and it stings like a b
with the audience score and a 95 great
returns all around it's gonna get into
any ivy league university it wants to
but really who are the five percent of
folks that think it's rotten
maybe they were confused because the
Grinch is green and rotten is green red
is fresh and these scores could make the
more recent versions turn Green With
Envy 2000's Grinch was a Smash Hit as
we've established but how did fare with
folks who watch movies for a pleasure
and a living
um yeah what's between waking up on
Christmas morning and finding the
Millennium Falcon under the tree versus
finding a lump of coal in your stocking
that would be 49 which is the Tomato
Meter number and it is rotten but I will
say that this very movie was a topic on
our podcast Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
hosted by Jacqueline Coley and some nerd
and it did age surprisingly well maybe
that's why the audience score climbs to
56 percent which I like to call Fresh
adjacent but it is still rotten which to
be fair that's probably how the Grinch
likes it
so now it appears to be Benedict
Cumberbatch is the Grinch acting as the
last hurdle for Boris Karloff to leap
over on his way to victory in this round
is the newest Grinch up to the task well
it's more so prepared than the 2000
version 59 is the 2018 flicks score and
that is as close as you can get to Fresh
while still being rotten the audience
was even colder to this one and I think
I might know why more on that later they
cried with a resounding 51 so there's no
threat to the Christmas classic here in
fact the only thing preventing me from
declaring the OG the winner here is this
fun little diatribe Benedict Cumberbatch
has voiced a few different animated and
CGI rendered folks in his day and if you
thought he might be too nice to play The
Grinch need I remind you he was also
Smaug in The Hobbit trilogy The
Desolation of Smaug is 74 at Battle of
the Five Armies is tied with his Grinch
at 59 he's also the frightening tiger
Shere Khan and Andy Circus is telling
you the Jungle Book and that is at 52
meanwhile Jim carries Grinch isn't his
only foray into the holiday season he
starred as Ebenezer Scrooge in Robert
zemeckis's A Christmas Carol which is
unfathomably rotten at 53 percent it's a
good movie right yes and this Grinch is
only his silver medal performance in the
world of Dr Seuss Jim also voiced Horton
in Horton Hears a Who which is fresh at
80 percent man that doctor really gets
around he also had a hit with the lorax
and I love all of his snitches and the
Yaks the eggs and the ham and the cat
and the hat maybe not that live-action
fever dream though the live-action Cat
in the Hat it's a 10 which is my cue to
say the original How the Grinch Stole
Christmas wins round two and is now on
the board it's one to one to zero as we
head into round three iconic moments and
now the playing field is truly leveled
kinda the feature films obviously have a
leg up because their running time is
considerably longer than the 26 minute
original but what Chuck Jones is
animated smash May lack in screen
minutes it more than makes up for with
memorable scenes and sequences I mean
the whole damn thing is Iconic right the
Tunes the who's the dog who actually got
a much meteor role in the show than he
did in the book in addition by Jones
with Seuss agreeing you see the original
book when you read it out loud generally
runs about 12 minutes so we needed more
packed into the show to fit that half
hour quota enter Max the only creature
keeping the Grinch's Cold Heart from
permanently plummeting into Sub-Zero
temperatures and this version shows that
green guy he is a Mean One Mr Grinch but
he does occasionally smile albeit when
he hatches a devious plan and him
sneaking around the slumbering whose is
another top-notch moment for me but yes
I am a sap when it all comes down to it
so it is a nice resolution when the
Grinch finally does get to carve the
roast beast that was all we really knew
about the guy until a much more thorough
backstory was employed in Ron Howard's
Vision again some of this was just
necessary to make the movie A
feature-length Affair and it wasn't
always easy does the name Geisel ring a
bell that's Theodore's last name and his
alter ego is Dr Seuss his wife had final
say over this grip when Howard and
Company were prepping for the 2000 film
and she made them earn it where it is it
took an eighth draft by the writing team
before she gave her blessing to proceed
once we did audiences got a glimpse into
what made the Grinch so anti-woo and
negative towards Christmas you see he
was bullied as a youngster for looking
different and one day he just pulled a
twisted sister and didn't take it
anymore he took off from Mount Crumpet
and never came back becoming something
of an urban legend to a younger
generation of who people it really does
an effective job of making you root for
the Grinch and with almost all of
Whoville being so obsessed with the
material possessions Christmas can
provide the audience has just one real
protagonist and that's Cindy Lou Who
okay I'm sorry two protagonists my bad
Max any Goodwill we feel for Jim
Carrey's iteration gets put to the test
when he ruins the Ville of whose holiday
celebration dancing on the grave of the
Fallen star from their Mighty tree
meanwhile Benedict cumberbatch's evil
one has a full artillery of props and
gizmos to play with because the world of
Animation can sled Beyond even the
bounds of what Ron Howard and his team
pulled off in live action the Christmas
thieves scene in 2018 works so well
complete with the Grinch's Madness and
Max's kinetic royalty to his best pal
and the climactic change of heart
sequence could melt the ticker in the
coldest of scrooches it's really a
testament to all three Productions and
Seuss's genius they were willing to
follow this character to the depths of
Torment yet with all three we welcome
him seeing the light and being invited
to engage in the spirit of giving with
his fellow who's so when it comes down
to it the question is simple do we have
30 minutes worth of iconic scenes in
either post-millennium version that
could stymie another win by the original
that's a good one well the animation is
top-notch in 2018 and the action flies
fast and furious and the set design and
commitment to craft by Carrie and the
rest of the cast and the 2000 flick is
admirable but none would be such a
wonderful remake that we'd forget about
why we care about this story in the
first place the OG How the Grinch Stole
Christmas from the 60s isn't just about
a holiday or a crusty creep it's a
perfect encapsulation of how us humans
need each other once in a while and
every moment still hits the perfect note
that's another win for the original in
round three and it takes the lead two to
one to nothing
round four such clatter but not the kind
that's going to make anyone spring from
their bed to see what's the matter oh no
[Music]
Ruckus is a fun one a result of the
musical Creations that accentuate Dr
Seuss's mythological Christmas Tale
which version wins the battle of the
soundtrack after all what good is a
Grinch yarn if you can't sing along with
it in your head
pour out loud in the shower I know it's
not just me the most iconic song is
obviously going to be a version of
You're a Mean One Mr Grinch first song
in the original by Boren no wait it
wasn't Karloff crooning That Tune most
folks assume so because who else could
get their voice that deep it was
actually thorough Ravenscroft and if
that name doesn't immediately ring a
bell it should because most of you have
had breakfast with him many times he was
also the voice of Tony the Tiger and
frosted flakes are very good but his
singing for How the Grinch Stole
Christmas is great he sounds enthralled
and disgusted by the Grinch at the same
time and the insult swab toward that
green guy up in the cave get more
creative with each passing verse Jim
Carrey himself took over for the 2000
version and Tyler the Creator handled
the duties for the 2018 film which was
narrated by none other than Pharrell
Williams in fact the entire 2018 movie
is loaded with songs that will get one
into candy cane season performed by a
host of luminaries everyone who from
Pentatonix to Nat King Cole shows up we
get Run Run Rudolph by the Brian Setzer
Orchestra Jackie Wilson doing Deck the
Halls run dmc's Christmas and Hollis for
crying out loud oh and some guy named
Danny Elfman contributed to the music as
well it was a stacked Feast for the ears
so could the year 2000s telling measure
up well they do have a James Horner his
work with the Whoville band is wackiness
to the nuttiest power everything from
loud quacking to fart noise is getting
involved in this Orchestra and it's the
right measure for a Whoville that might
be a little too into the holiday spirit
or maybe they're missing the point
entirely Buster Rhymes and Carrie teamed
up for the Grinch 2000 track and were
also traded to Grammy faves like Faith
Hill doing where are you Christmas and
in sync belting out you don't have to be
alone and if this wasn't clearly a turn
of the Millennium movie already names
like Ben Folds Smash Mouth and Bare
Naked Ladies should clue you in Horner's
main theme really tugs on the
heartstrings when we're finally carving
that roast beast but the real separation
between the two reimaginings why in the
sheer originality of the 2000 production
2018 sound track may be easier on the
ears for the kiddos or the adults who
are grinching day after day until
December 25th but it does play more like
a Christmas Greatest Hits than a grinch
Centric album
not that there's anything wrong with
that I love me some holiday Tunes I say
Bing Nat Brenda Lee I'll even do
Band-Aid do they know it's Christmas
time at all on my gym playlist around
this time of year and I hope that places
are reigning Winter Queen Mariah Carey
we are not worthy and just in case
originality a number of songs didn't
seal the deal for How the Grinch Stole
Christmas 2000 here comes the closer
that Whoville medley features the
Trans-Siberian Orchestra the ass kickers
of Christmas they got Carol the bells
wizards of winter another Grinch Cannon
yeah that's enough to earn a w in my
book the year 2000 gets another win and
we're tied at two to two and 2018's the
Grinch just has one chance left to get
on the board
Wild Card round mirror mirror on the
wall who's the fairest Grinch of them
all or maybe unfairest is the better
adjective you'd want to describe a dude
named the Grinch so that's what we'll
investigate for this final all
determining phase will the 1966 or 2000
How the Grinch Stole Christmas get the
verses when outright or will 2018 muck
up the proceedings and score the final
point of the match all have High Hopes
but the round will be won simply by
who's the best Grinch Benedict
Cumberbatch in his version do have a lot
going for them dude was great in the
role and anyone that didn't think
Sherlock could pull off a villainous
type row like that remember we talked
about him he was smag the dragon shirk
on the tiger and Doctor Strange the
frequent ass hell even detective homes
can get prickly very easily but Steven
strange he's actually a good cop for the
Grinch he's content with his lifestyle
albeit one that doesn't really put a
premium on self-actualization or
betterment see this Grinch grew up in
orphan and seeing all the happiness
around the holidays for others may have
put him off to the idea celebrating
anything it's a softer more relatable
Grinch than we had known from the 60s
but right in line with the character's
maturation through the decades Carrie's
take gave us a bully victim backstory
opening the doors for us to care about
him somewhat even when he did become a
psycho around wintertime we can
sympathize with both modern versions of
the Grinch but we still want to see them
Green With Envy to the point where they
hatch Fantastical plots to steal the day
before boxing day I didn't forget about
you Canada thanks for all the Jim
Carrey's John Candy's Martin shorts Rick
Moranis says Mike Myers is and all the
other funny folks you've given us now
give it a rest us American comedians
need stage time too we can't all book
The Grinch roll whenever the Polar
Express comes around again Carrie's
Grinch can be related to at least on
screen but what a villager took to get
him there the makeup and Prosthetics
used to transform Jim into Mr G were
extensive cumbersome and time-consuming
hours before and after each shoot day to
put it on and take it off Carrie was
such a pain to work with the times early
on the revered special effects makeup
artist kazuhiro tsuchi who also worked
on men in Black Hellboy and turned Gary
Oldman into Winston Churchill for
darkest hour he quit for a couple of
weeks and sought therapy after
production wrapped he only returned for
the rest of the shoot after Carrie
called and apologized and for Jim this
was the tail end of his Andy Kaufman
transformation and he was still coming
out of character or maybe Andy was still
coming out of gym early shoots and
pre-production discussions sometimes
necessitated Ron Howard and Company
addressing Jim as Andy or Acer Stanley
or Lloyd or cable guy for his part Kerry
almost quit after day one and needed the
help of a CIA training operative to
teach him torture endurance he also
stayed Alive by listening to copious
amounts of the Bee Gees in his trailer
by the way y'all see that BG's
documentary last year it's great stuff
makes the perfect holiday gift but at
the end of the day you just can't go
wrong with the OG Grinch Boris Karloff
technically narrates it when he's acting
out the Grinch we feel that green Globs
wit wisdom and piccadillos through the
horror movie icons bass voiced draw he's
not a dummy and we don't know all of
this Grinch's backstory just that his
heart was simply too small to celebrate
amongst the joy-filled Whos and therein
lies of Simplicity that still feels
magical around this time of year as
amazing a feat as it was to pull off a
film like two thousands How the Grinch
Stole Christmas and as fun as a 2018 the
Grinch Shenanigans were not every
concept is best fitted for a feature
film run just under 30 action-packed
minutes is all that were needed to
convey everything about the Grinch the
denizens of Whoville and the inner
conflict that revolves around Christmas
time and it's that original telling of
the Grinch that still stands tallest and
not just among his other big screen
peers
did you know that over the years folks
Like Walter Matthau Seth Green Dan
castellanetta and Stephen Stanton have
voiced some version parody or otherwise
of the world's most famous Zeus
antagonist but when TV Guide rated the
Grinch at number five for their greatest
cartoon characters of all time we knew
exactly which one they were talking
about the original Grinch wins the Wild
Card round and thus takes the match what
is the deal but I must admit the 2000
version gave the OG all it could handle
and I do enjoy the 2018 take as well in
fact if this episode of verses had been
about which Max the dog Incarnation was
the best I might lean towards 2018 but
we do get a real dog in the 2000 film
let's put a pin in this and address it
next year maybe another episode for now
let us know your favorite Grinch on
social media I'm at Mark Ellis live and
keep it tuned right here to Rotten
Tomatoes for all the latest in the world
of movies TV and everything in between
thanks for watching versus all you whose
and until next time I'm Mark Ellis and I
miss tenderly sweet as a seasick
crocodile
[Applause]
foreign